in my part of the presentation i will
briefly talk about
what the
level topics are that we're going to
cover
and discuss how you might benefit from
participating in the program what might
be the possible outcomes i'll introduce
you to some of the mentors that will be
helping you along the way and show you
some examples of students that have
completed this program and what they
have done with the information that they
received
so as you all know
we live in the age of data and
specifically in biomedical research or
in biology there's a growing
source of data and one data in
particular called next generation
sequencing data is becoming uh kind of
the foundation of a lot of the different
research topics that are being
done in biomedical research and
agriculture and biotechnology etc so my
background is actually not in
bioinformatics but i came into
bioinformatics by working with pine
biotech and the different collaborators
that include multiple research
universities
biomedical
research projects and consortia and i
had the privilege of
training
and
working alongside experts and students
in many different institutions here in
the u.s
so as a result of that
i've seen how
it's really unpredictable to know
who becomes uh you know an expert and
who leaves and who kind of chooses
bioinformatics is their topic and for a
lot of people what i've discovered is
it's not clear what bioinformatics
actually is and how is it applied in a
variety of domains
so my first part of today's session is
to explain why bioinformatics and what
is bioinformatics and how data in
biomedical research is actually used to
advance the application of insights from
such analyses to
advanced precision medicine
biotechnology agriculture etc so
first of all kind of a historical
background since the
1950s when the dna was first discovered
the structure of dna was clarified we've
seen how such information has led to
nudity discoveries starting from the
sequencing annotation and discovery of
the human genome and the genes that are
responsible for different proteins to
technologies that make such data easy to
produce
and eventually to use
in large-scale initiatives like genomics
england
the broad institute
different
medical centers that actually use
insights from genomic data to categorize
diagnose and treat patients
now the basis of that is that
when we understand the code and we
understand what the code actually uh
produces so how nucleotide sequences
form amino acid sequences that are the
basis of proteins we can start looking
at variation of that dna code that is
responsible for some specific phenotype
or in this case in this example you can
see sickle cell anemia actually a change
in a particular
amino acid leads to a change in
a cell structure right
and so
that kind of an ability to
detect changes
has led to a number of very clear
applications so for example drug
metabolism how different individuals
metabolize different drugs and whether
they will respond or not respond to
treatment
identification of mutations in cancer
cells identifying genetic predisposition
or disorders like sickle cell
anemia inherited mutations
rare genetic diseases
as well as drug resistance and different
pathogens and these examples are all in
the context of biomedical research and
medical application in the context of
precision or personalized medicine
because what happens in the medical
context is today clinicians have to deal
with such information to actually make
a better um description or
characterization of disease for a
patient and and one of the things that
we now are starting to see is that you
have these panels of
specific genes specific
proteins
and
you can now identify mutations that are
responsible for
very dangerous diseases like cancer now
as researchers continue to study these
they actually understand that
some specific genes in the genome are
responsible for the most
serious effects so for example tumor
suppressor genes on protein genes dna
repair genes they accumulate mutations
that are most dangerous one example is
the tp-53 mutation that
is a gene p53 protein
tumor protein p53 is encoded in that
gene and what that mutation does is it
can actually alter the structure of that
protein and make it not functional and
if it's not functional it's a tumor
suppressor gene so then it does not
suppress the tumor growth because it
does not respond to the damage in the
dna and leads to accumulation of
mutations so finding such mutations can
be critical for accurate and precise and
effective cancer cancer treatment
in cystic fibrosis
you have
mutations that are responsible for the
functioning of
the cftr channel
which is responsible for
getting the right kind of uh
chloride ions out of the cells and if
it's not functioning it leads to
accumulation of mucus and can be very
dangerous so knowing how to find these
mutations and understand their function
is clearly important and not only is
this important for individual mutations
this is also important for large scale
rearrangements like copy number
variation
repeats that expand a particular region
and and one way to find those variations
is to perform genome-wide analyses that
take thousands of samples for clear
phenotypes and start understanding what
are the statistically significant
patterns that occur in a large
proportion of the population
such studies have led to discoveries
including tuberculosis drug resistance
which is a disease that is affecting
millions of individuals around the world
if someone can monitor the participants
and make sure that no one
think if you could keep them unmuted
thank you
so drug resistance
not only to individual drugs but
multiple drugs is starting to become a
huge problem
and and we see the same in the
world of viral pathogens so for example
the ebola outbreak and how that leads to
tracking of transmission and vaccine
design but also the current pandemic of
covert 19 we hear about variance of
concern all the time so all of these
project examples all of these
you know examples in precision medicine
in population health
genetic predisposition to disease all of
these have been transformed by the
availability of these different types of
sequencing techniques so in the program
what we will try to do is introduce you
to how such data is generated
what is the process of acquiring actual
digital data from a biological sample
and then in that data set how do we work
with
different algorithms computational
algorithms to understand mutations that
are pathogenic neutral
that are maybe not very bad or bad
and how do we determine the effect of
these mutations in the genome so how do
we actually
categorize them how do we understand
their impact on the phenotype and what
are some examples where you can find uh
the you know clear association between
individual mutations and the phenotype
and so that is really what
bioinformatics is all about so
bioinformatics is about taking
information or data
taking methods of computational analysis
statistical methods machine learning
analytical methods and applying them to
biological data sets applying them to
data sets where we have biological
samples conditions clinical conditions
etc and so the program is going to
tie together these three different
domains
in a way that you can quickly see the
application of bioinformatics to a
number of different domains so the
omixlogic
programs are going to help you not only
understand how these things work but
also practice and apply them and so in
the context of this program these
resources that were already mentioned by
sri gauri are going to be critical to
getting you from maybe not knowing a lot
about bioinformatics to getting an
understanding of what bioinformatics is
and how it applies to eventually
starting to use it maybe in your own
project or a group
and so here
we're going to try to cover a variety of
different types of
examples or projects that are case
studies that you can use
to really understand and develop a sense
of you personally discovering something
on your own using some of these tools
now i imagine that most of you here have
understanding of what bioinformatics is
maybe not a lot of experience and that
is really who the program is for
now i want to specifically highlight
two
project or two resources
on the onyx logic portal
where you can get started so even if
you're here for the first time
now that you have registered you can go
to the omixlogic portal and find two
specific courses one is called
introduction to bioinformatics
and another one is called bytes and
molecules so uh sparse or trigori
somebody maybe can uh
yeah someone can maybe post the links
uh so if you have
an account and you've signed up again
the sign up is free
those are two introductory courses that
will get you started they will get you
into this context they will explain at a
high level the different applications
and introduce you to our community the
way that things are organized and you
will really get a good sense of why
bioinformatics is it for me and what can
i do with it
okay thank you tash so introduction to
bioinformatics is that first course and
the second course that i wanted to
mention is called bytes and molecules
so again if you search here bytes and
molecules it is course two and this
course is
different from the introduction to
bioinformatics because it is a little
bit more detailed and actually
introduces a lot of the concepts that
are going to be useful for what we do in
this program and that includes
terminology or what are these terms like
snips
you know variance gene expression
profiles etc it will give you a sense of
the relationship between
code
and structure and how things work in the
cell
and then it will introduce you to
specific types of data that could be
that could be acquired from next
generation sequencing so genomics
transcriptomics and metagenomics and
talk a little bit about maybe things
that you haven't thought of how
bioinformatics is actually used to study
precision medicine or astronaut health
in space
now also a big component of
bioinformatics as i mentioned is the
application of data analysis techniques
and tools to large data sets and coding
is a critical component so as you've
seen one of the critical elements is to
understand how and why and then have the
practical skills and so the second
option that was mentioned in the
beginning so the first one was genomics
in the virtual lab the second one was
coding or biomedical data analysis in r
and python so in this course you will
already get an introduction to
coding in r which is a popular
method of analyzing different types of
biological data where you will have
access to different examples of just
getting to know what coding is why do we
need coding and how to read
use
to load the data things like that so
that's going to be very useful because
one of the practical examples here is
the ability to actually
run code and practice fixing the code
that is given to you without having to
you know
take too much time of
yours
to actually learn everything from
scratch so we're not going to learn
things like hello world we're going to
jump into how to load data and this data
is going to be biological data or the
type of data that you are expected to
use in the domain of bioinformatics and
once we get into this you will see that
you will start to appreciate syntax you
will know how to load and produce
simple plots that are informative you
will
interpret these plots and then as it
becomes more and more complex so here
you will find assignments
those will introduce you to more and
more complex methods of analysis
including analysis of complex data
analysis using complex methods like
machine learning and deep learning and
also ability to integrate multiple
sources of information to actually
answer real research questions
so along the way as you go through this
course work you will realize that a lot
of this course work is sourced from
experts in the field
and experts in the field are people that
have a long history of
maybe doing research or using such
skills in the domain of biotechnology
and pharma
and getting to know these people you
will realize that they all have a rich
history and a path of how they got to
where they are today so
to briefly introduce some of these
people
i want to
highlight a couple examples
and those examples are going to
demonstrate kind of the quality of the
people that you will be
exposed
[Music]